[Music]
hello and welcome back to another
fun night with dorsa
i am
forgetting which number this is but i
know where to continue number five thank
you we are on part five of uh french
uh we've had a bunch of segways we've
done a bunch of filler doors i know
that's people seem to really enjoy it
when i talked my personal games and how
i prepared it why i did what i did and
how i learned that opening so
i'm continuing those and i feel like
it's a little bit too honest because if
i'm playing another series tournament
anytime soon that'll be
a little little problematic
but hey
well anything from my students and my
viewers
so
um
yeah we
to
kind of circle back i the the way that i
kind of learned how to play really good
in french
and uh kind of kurokon and a little bit
of philidor was because i read that the
specific book
that paimarjun margin wrote
oh my god 2014
15.
it's been a little while but it's still
relevant and the the opening still holds
as you can see
um so it's something that if you want to
just gain a better understanding of this
middle games how to avoid the super
specific
main lines and how to just make sure
your opponent is annoyed
i do recommend
nikki's books the first one was about
french carl con philidor
the the other three were sicilian and
the last one was
miners miter defenses i have not
actually read the last one yet
anywho i want to go ahead and jump in
because it's been a very long week
already
uh so
the one that i'm going to show you is
like the last time we talked a little
more in depth about bishop g5 on bishop
g5 was something that i play very
frequently on and off but i also hold a
special place in my heart for e5
so i'm gonna take a second and just kind
of get a little bit of vote who plays
this he who has encountered this
position in like let's say last two
years as white or black
okay i see
oh my god i see so many hats i did not
expect that cool
well i guess if you're in a french class
you probably have encountered
french positions before
all right okay great i see a bunch of
people in the chat are also
agreeing that they have encountered this
which is wonderful
so uh the thing to keep in mind is that
again you are not obligated to to always
play bishop g5 or always play e5 but
with bishop g5 i i
i got burned a little to be honest there
was a specific game that just really
really burned me bad um it was i'll just
give you this before we close the bishop
g5 chapter i
ha it was like 2015 world youth
championship and i was playing on board
one and if i win i have a really clear
shot that's getting first if i don't
then my opponent has like was she was
playing a really good uh it was
mahalakshmi um she was playing really
good she was
about to win the tournament but if she
won she was like definitely gonna win
the tournament if i won then i was
probably going to win the tournament so
it was like one of those tournaments one
of those games
so i had this all prepared and i went to
the game and i felt so good about it
and
for some reason i just my position
started to really collapse like really
bad
like terribly and i thought you know i
mean upland is doing stuff i'm doing
stuff
and that is not the case
she just
it was really really bad
and i lost the 430th move
needless to say it was a very fun
game after that
i still i mean i think i think there was
still a few rounds left and i played
them and
they were still very fun tournaments
uh so many memories are passing by
ah man world youth world junior always
was so much fun but i'm just showing you
a very general reason on why i don't um
who won the tournament
in my category which was girls under 18
2015 um my lakshmi did want it
it was like she was one of those but
like we were both she was playing for
india i was playing for iran so we
always played in like asian dudes and
then world views and then every year we
just played and played and played and
oh my god i was running out of openings
to play against her but she won this one
and anyways um i'm just showing you why
uh why i am not the biggest fan of it
just this bishop b4 really burned me
one too many times so i'm still a little
sore
sour sore
all right so i i started to get more
into e5
now
knight's gotta go now what do we do
probably you already know the opening if
you don't know us on the study as well
but what do you think is a good idea for
whites right now
yep
what is a good idea for black
what is a very typical thing in this
pawn structure
and we also want to try and develop we
don't want to take that before we have
to
and now um i've seen people play this
multiple different ways but i am very
comfortable with bishop v3
so
black has a few ideas i'm going to show
you the the the craziest one first
with queen b6 all right
what do you think this queen wants here
why did my opponent just make this move
yeah
and some eyes on this right so we have
to be careful because if if we are
setting up to do long cast so well
that's going to be problem for us so
what is a good idea for white
if you know the opening great if you
don't know it try to reason through it
that is true you're completely correct
let's say they give the check
that is also very correct because i mean
your knives under attacks either you
have to bring the ice back or c3 so c3
makes more sense now
let's say they take you can't take back
with the pawn you could take with the
knight or bishop or you could be for it
which one
well knight is okay but
how about pawn to b4 because that if
that works that would be great to inter
meso you already get to kick the queen
away
there is quite a lot of theory in b4
um i'll actually show you a little bit
of it
you're not obligated to play before if
you don't want to you can't take it but
if you do take it then knight takes
let's say you take back and pawn b5 and
then you have to kind of think knight c5
and then take and then b4 and can get a
little too
comfortable for opponent and i don't
like to give my opponent that many
chances so let's stay with b4
now let's say they take it we take back
bishop takes b4 is the best one what's a
good idea for whites right now we gotta
stop the check
this guy is falling
so it should be a easy peasy bishop d2
find
they take we gotta take back with the
knight so up until here is pretty forced
now opponent has uh b5 which is the best
and somebody played castle against me
let's look at castle first to see why
it's a little bit worse
so why do you think that is what does
castle give us that
b5 earlier wouldn't
uh
so
i agree thank you chad let's see what
about in person
queen b3 um i'm not a poster queen b3
but i feel like if you do queen b3 i
mean i kind of want to go b5 anyways
so this stops it that's fair if i get
this that's great i agree but what if if
you go queen b3 they
hm so you're stopping this
but you're also kind of not just setting
up for castle so what if i try to
open up my rook
because if take then knight could take
and knight wants to jump here
and you're not fast enough to castle
even if you get bishop d3 i'll still go
knight e4 you take i take you can't stop
this
so because opponent has this much the
power in the center you have to be fast
bishop d3 is kind of a must
and after bishop d3 let's say they go b5
you retract the knight and the game that
i have my opponent 29 b6
and i kind of simply got to castle
and i got myself into this situation
which is totally good
and this was a really comfortable game
for me
if only if i can remember when slash
where i played it
um
i know there was one a game here there
was another game that had a little bit
of a move order difference i'll get into
that as well
but this would be really comfortable you
move it away now i'm bringing my attack
here if g6 will crate
if f6 then i can also take if you take
with the rook i'm still gonna know g5 it
and i have a bunch of threads here
so i'm very comfortable with this as
well
so let me go back
i'm gonna do a big jump let's say here
what if they play b5 first what now
kind of have to go knights b2 right
now let's say uh knight goes to b6 to
still want to do those knight c4 ideas
so the difference here is that comparing
this line with the shorts castle and
having the bishop on d3 line is that
black could be like saving a move by not
castling so how does that help
uh muhammad is asking can i can i ask
how many hours do you train per day
oh man right now i'm just teaching
teaching counts as training
that's going to be a lot of hours
i'm not preparing for a specific
tournament so i'm not trading
the
as a professional chess player would
so it's kind of different
when i am preparing for a specific
tournament then i would be doing
oh my god opening prep getting sharper
the evaluation understanding what the
position needs oh my god end games and
games
so
it really depends on why am i preparing
what is the purpose of the training
so
why to move what do we do here
you know what your opponent wants to do
um
there's a
huge imbalance
let me just put my foot here make sure
that's good
so what do we think
i'm getting a bunch of knight b trees
man i wish i could play knight b3
or queen b3 is in the chat the problem
with queen b3 is still knight c4
surprisingly the best one is a4 because
you want to combat this knight c4 and if
knight c4 happens now you get to take
attack the queen
now if the queen takes it well awesome
now i'm attacking the
this knight with three they're only
defending with two i'm very happy about
this
let's see what else is there
um
there is a kind of interesting king of
two as well that i kind of tried once in
a police game i just didn't really
understand why i was doing it though
so i'm not really recommending that but
i do recommend a4
now in the real game when my opponent
played this so this was a how did i put
it uh opponent should have uh
played
castle first
to make sure that we develop
to kind of kind of put the king in
safety then go b5 and then we don't
really have a pawn a4
as fast i mean white is still better
that's kind of why the the the
peace sacrifice for black doesn't work
but this would be the the better
situation for black but in a different
game my opponent decided to kind of mix
up the move order a little bit but now i
could have had a four but i kind of
didn't
and then i went queen f3 and i put the
queen on d3 and it made things really
awkward
i knew i kind of had advantage but it
was just so hard to get the pieces
moving
i ended up winning the game um but i'm
still going to like
do a huge jump here because there is not
much
theory in this specific situation that i
want to talk about
big jump big jump coming up
so that's kind of the big thing i wanted
to talk about when it comes to queen b6
now let's talk about difference line
let's talk about asics how do you feel
about asics
i've only had a very few games in this i
mean there is a theory in it
but game wise i've had less
wait wait i'm seeing something in the
chat that i feel like i should respond
to
okay that was funny so
there's a discussion about
how to become an i am
and uh the the answer seems to be to
become an i am you must beat items and
they're very good at chess and rarely
lose hope
and
um
so the trick
the becomes figuring out how some
unwinnable positions can be won
i mean
this buddy james is not really wrong per
se
but man you should have seen the dirty
flags people did did me
when i was playing like what two hours
ago there's a lot of dirty flagging
that's not the case it's not that we
it's not that the title players is
rarely lose we're just
more experienced and more tricky and
kind of know which buttons to push
or not to push
but um the the main thing is no that's
not how getting norms and titles work
exactly you do need to you need to
it's it has to be a fetus uh tournaments
it's free the rated events you can't
play uscf event and game speedy titles
you need to play feta rated tournaments
you need to be playing
a certain number of
titled opponents even ims gm's legends
lm they count depending on what title
you're trying to get
you need to gain a certain
performance rating so it's not your
rating that needs to cross a certain
level but also that you're you need to
have a specific performance rating in
that specific tournament that you're
getting it's a title uh norm from
and you need to
you need to have at least three norms so
like you need to have three different
tournaments that you have had that's
great performance which you would obtain
by beating the title players but
we have a
viewer saying swallowing an engine
sounds like an easier way to beat items
and gm's
i don't know that's just not comfortable
and digestions and how would i
understand what the engine is saying i
would turn into a weird
nah that's too complicated just strange
us
all right
back to it now what do you want to do
here
a6 what's a good idea for us
let me start by which side do you think
you're going to castle
most likely yes so
but i mean if you just go ahead and play
bishop d3 then queen b6 would be more
problematic
so you need to start preparing for this
queen b6 as well
because since opponent's pawn is up here
there's tension between these two pawns
right so because of the pawn structure
the way it seems to be is that
the you are going to want to like do f5
and stuff an opponent is going to want
to do stuff in your queen side so as
long as you can neutralize the attack
that opponents will do in the queen side
and at the same time keep your attack in
the king side you should have an easy
understanding of what's going on now
some of the things that black can do to
kind of mess with your hopes and dreams
in king side is f6 or f5
so keep that in mind as well
but right now a3 is possible queen d2 is
possible
i was quite a big fan of queen d2 and
after queen d2 let's say opponent goes
ahead and plays pawn to b5
now yes we don't really want a long
castle anymore i agree with that what i
think is a good idea there are
few ideas that are good but what seems
right to you
a3
i like a3 tk3 is totally fine
then you're gonna probably get this
bishop out and start
heading for castle yeah that's
completely fine uh in this specific game
um i wanted to take because i was
actually just learning about this
specific pawn structure so i wanted to
give it a try there's nothing wrong with
take but
let me just keep this position in mind
let me just do a mini jump back if
bishop goes to e7
then when we take and if the bishop
takes it kind of feels a little bit more
prepared for
especially because opponents kind of
wasted a move and then took it
so
i was getting deeper in understanding
these specific pawn structures but then
when my opponents played asics i was
like man i've been
sorry a6 then i was like oh man i've
been preparing for the specific
structures i want to try it let's just
take it
that is not the very good decision to
make but it was a fine move so i don't
have anything against it
and i kind of wanted to see if my
opponents would do this super super cool
potential
blender
what do you think is a good move for
whites right now
i'm sorry
why knight to e4
the weirdest thing is i think i've seen
this before
it's possible
yeah because of these d6 basically
you're attacking the bishop
and you're attacking d6 and
there's just
a lot of tricks well
yeah a lot of people would say bishop e4
bishop before is actually not good
because knight is denied b6
i mean even if you take they take back
and you're just losing too much and
gaining too little
so d4 knight takes knight takes knight
e4r is the best one
the idea is well first of all if you
move the bishop well then hallelujah
you move it now i guess bishop e4 you
don't have knights b6 anymore
if you don't move it if you let go queen
b6 then i can take
if you take with the knights well this
guy drops so let's say queen takes now
boom c3
um let's see let's say let's just castle
then i could try and take it and then
after take i could just you know take
over here because if you take i have
this discovery attack why am i erroring
while i can just
do this
but i would also prefer to to make it a
little bit more comfortable on you so if
you were to go short castle why not just
c3 this is already pinned right
there's two attackers one defenders i'm
enjoying this
yeah
goody
all right um so i was i think a part of
me was kind of um hoping my opponent
would play this d4 and blunder
but the kid didn't the kid knew what he
was doing
and then i had to enter this end game
which i do think is definitely worth
looking into because of how the the the
pawns are
so let's take a second and talk
let's just see what do you think is
going on here what's something that
white wants what's something that black
wants
so what is going on here
anything specific
yeah so white's gonna want to do stuff
in the d4 square so what do you think is
a good idea for black
um there seems to be a bunch of fight
going to happen about this square
okay let me let me rephrase my question
what do you think is black's biggest
problem
yeah this bishop is the same color as
these pawns right
so blacks that's kind of the biggest
problem that black is facing so black
would like to be able to resolve that
and that could happen if black can get
d4 and this bishop is here right so your
main priority should be to move this
knight put c3 and put a knight here
so that's kind of what i tried to do
my pawn is kind of stopping my c3 so i
had to play it a little more creative
and
it got a little weird
but i had advantage and it was just a
matter of how to convert and it took
another 20 30 move to convert it to a
full win but
the endgame is now comfortable
so my point is that when you're learning
openings it's not just about
memorization it's also about
understanding the pawn structure and
like okay let's say you put the queens
off then what are you doing let's say
you keep the queens then what are you
doing so it's about the center the
weaknesses the structure the king safety
it's about the whole thing it's not just
about memorizing openings which
it's sometimes really hard for people to
understand when they're just looking at
openings they'll literally just go
engine did that and the engine engine
engine or like master games played this
i have so many kids who like asked me
about a specific opening just because
they heard it's cool like somebody
played it on a stream and i'm like
like this is a whole different thing
that you do not play you're never going
to play because it's not your style and
you're just asking me about it because
you think it says a cool name
so many kids love the dragon opening and
i'm like
just like just because it's dragon and
i'm like
well how about the other dragon okay
no i i can't really do that because they
can actually watch streamers and there's
only one dragon opening
um but
yeah so oh
my heart
yeah
we have to be very careful with your
opening choices
all right i'm going to do a big jump
back
yeah so let's talk about bishop e7 now
what do we think
i like that why
um
no you're not drunk um i feel like if my
opponent kind of closes up the center i
wouldn't mind casting this way but as
long as like it's the tension is here i
don't i don't know if i want to do it
wait wait what am i talking about no no
no if opponent closes up i don't want to
castle but as long as the tension is
here i'm still kind of undecided
i want to have the option
so yes queen d2 is good you also might
want to go queen f2 to kind of start
bugging this pawn
let's say castle now what
how are we feeling
there are okay i'm getting a lot of
bishop b5 questions bishop b5 is not the
place to be for your bishop first of all
even if you come here and you take this
they take back and they get bishop a6
which i don't think we do i don't want
and yeah if i can't have this diagonal
that would be ideal for me right now
it's not really i can't really do that
because they can push
but
this is this is a good bishop i don't
want to just take it but take them that
night with this
all right what else we got
it's very possible but remember we i
kind of mentioned that after bishop e7
we might want to take and if they take
back they've lost the tempo
so why not that
why did that
um i kind of wanted for the castle to
happen first
i mean we could take it but then they
take and i i'm not trying to take it i'm
trying to queen detour it
so
i guess it could just transpose but
this kind of makes it a little bit more
tricky
just a little bit
it is possible but what is f6
because the rook is in front of the
queen that's kind of giving me some
questionable
thoughts
so let's say take let's say first things
first
bishop takes back
now what
can we lawn castle now
i agree
let's say queen a5 now what
they're trying to create an attack but
because the center is
less
locked now we don't have to
be that worried
kb1 is fine
but can i just take this
and then then take back then i can just
develop
i don't think king b1 is bad but it
feels like it's a
extreme it gives them extra
opportunities
and you know how i feel about slightly
happy opponents they shouldn't exist
so
yeah the idea is if i can figure the
center out before i make a decision
about castle i get both both ways but if
they take with the knights now what
actually let me show you um
how this game actually turned out
because this was a real game that i had
and it was just so nice i'm attacking
left and right and then again at
attacking attacking attacking
and like i knew i had a bit of an
advantage pretty much the whole game
but it was really hard to convert it
until i actually got a nice
i stopped their attack and i have extra
material
so
all right i'm going to do a big jump
back and i know it was like we kind of
went fast but i'm not trying to
my main focus is the the opening and the
spawn structure and the middle games
that could follow this is not a typical
middle game that would follow and
because it was a little weird
it the game isn't a study if you would
like to pay more
time on it but all right let's stay with
knight takes c5 now let's
can we steal lawn castle or should we
start planning on short castle
i'm sorry
are you sure
no
that's not you're right i'm just trying
to trick you
i should be like look whenever you're
thinking there should be like two doors
here like an angel doorstop saying yeah
is that are you sure that's a devil door
swing no no no no that's not a good idea
so
it reminds me of halloween
exactly
exactly
i did have a the weird devil
mixed with
red riding hood costume
i had a red writing costume
yeah i couldn't find my wings i
eventually found my wings though
it was an emergency devil horn find
thing at the end anyways it was quite
fun
so yes there should be one of that one
of that
so i'm trying to kind of trick you all
the time
i'm also trying to guide you all the
time
all right so long castle is nice
um i can't tell you i mean i can't
really justify bishop b2 it's okay
there's nothing specifically wrong with
it but it also doesn't really do the
things we wanted to do
um
yeah i'm bored with long castle
so let's see
let's say opponent tries to attack me
what are we to do
that's fair how
would you start
i'll be
g3
g3 why
oh if i play ashran they take it i'm
happy
so happy
it sure is possible but uh yeah right h4
is definitely possible but if you do h4
they can also go b5
so i kind of wanted to this was actually
a little bit of an off game of mine i
went to queen f2
and then i kind of continued it with g4
and it i i kind of waited around too
long and my opponent got a little too
comfortable
and i lost the game i mean he was like
2600 i think
wait actually no this is the game that i
drew how did i drill this
oh this is a different game sorry
different experience here i played
queenie one in a different game yeah
and i lost this real bad this one i
remember
and i was i don't even know what i was
trying to do this is like this is not
even a cheap trick
it's just a weird trick
and my nights is just so weird here and
like my king is so left alone on his own
and
yeah i lost this real bad uh but
the good idea here queenie like queen f2
clean ones are not bad but h4 makes more
sense to get the pieces rolling first to
get those pawns going
uh or or if you really want to like play
chill king b1 also makes sense then b5
then you can push g4 or h4
so the moves that you do should be
either you know king safety or push push
because if you do what i did with my
queen ideas it gets a little slow what
about pawn f5 how did you feel about
that could that work
if they don't take i'm gonna try to have
sixes so let's say they take
i will take over here
and then what are they gonna do let's
say bishop e6 now what do you think is a
good idea for whites now
responding bishop to g4
or c4
um it's possible would you would you
want to take it though
or do you feel feisty enough to give
this check
because if they take you can take back
if they take
you can't take back if they take this
false
if they don't take well this is falling
so this could be a nice nice way to play
it
f5 i think it's like the the chillest
way to play it
if you don't want to get yourself into
those attacks uh between like they
attack you you attack then if you don't
want to get yourself in those then f5
would be the the chillest way
but you have to remember what's going on
all right i'm gonna do a mini uh jump
back actually let's talk about queen a5
anything here what would you do here
getting a few king b ones in the chat
a3
okay let's see
my king is castle in the queen slide
they want to do a queenside pawn storm
if i play a3 then it kind of gives them
a new target to come attack
is not you know it's not losing but it
does give opponent a lot of hopes and
dreams to come attack it and whenever
i'm around we don't want happy opponents
and if i if anything i do would make my
opponent happy if i even can't find the
chest reason for not doing it that's
good enough reason for me to not do it
so
no no
so yeah king b1 makes sense your queen
is here you might have some hopes and
dreams for a2 i'm just going to king b1
and wish block you there we go
all right let's go back
up what about
b6 how do you feel about b6
oh sorry that's usually
sure
so you can see the chance
yeah that's the one thing with leeches i
don't know how to
keep my brain happy with my screen and
keep you happy without the
extra stuff
thanks
f5 is a little too early to be honest
but the thing is
even if you are looking at the engine
there are so many
potential lines that you're just going
to get confused so now it's just more
about your understanding your experience
and what's
what doesn't make opponents happy f5 is
not a bad idea
but it does give opponents slight
chances
if they take that's cool because they
can take it
what if they don't take what if they go
like 94.
i guess the point i'm trying to make is
that's f5 not a bad idea
h4 not a bad idea
queen f2 or e1 not a bad idea
but at this moment it's more about your
choice as long as you don't give
opponents more help on attacking your
king and you're doing something to
attack their king it's fine you can
start with h4 g4 try to bring your queen
over
um you would like to be able to do f5 f6
opponents might be able to do f6 so
there's a lot of stuff that are
happening
so kind of
up to you because b6 is actually a
threatening move i'm not really
challenged by this move
all right so we want to trade bishops
um even if they do i'm not obligated to
take it i can just wait until you take
me and i'll take you and i'm still
attacking here
let's say we go h4 they go bishop a6
even if i don't want it even if there's
no tactics anything there's just like
purely no tactics even if i just
continue pushing and you take me
i will simply just take it back with
either one of the rooks there are
tactics there but even if they're not
this is doesn't this doesn't really
concern me because you're spending two
moves exchanging a bishop that i have
not developed
of course here this bishop takes c5 and
if them take then i can take and i mean
happy stuff
all right um now a final line that we
should cover is what if take
what would you take that back with
sorry what would be the idea
no just like a normal move to see how to
develop how tickets because both like
white's position in that situation is
comfortable but black's position is also
not really threatened so now it just
becomes how to continue this position
type of
yep we gotta take it with knight i agree
let's say bishop c5 now what
so you see it's a very similar middle
game similar structures similar
center stuff
similar ideas
now since the the tension here is gone
between those pawns we could consider
long castle we don't have to but we do
have the option so
now let's say they castle
now what
honestly yeah i don't see why not you
could start with like h4 or like queen
f2 or stuff but i'm totally happy with
this too and now if they continue their
ideas not g4 if they take take that's
still totally fine
i actually had a very
stressful game
i was playing this closed uh tournament
and it was like oh she was sitting
semi-close there were multiple of them i
played and i was playing a grand master
who was like 24 98 and it was the first
round and i was like ah if i lose then
there goes the potential norm and stuff
deal with so much harder so i was just
trying to not lose and i was just trying
to keep my okay like hold my end
and just try to play okay i wasn't
trying to do something too crazy but i
also don't want to give too much
advantage or lose too much advantage
so we got into this position and i got
an advantage and i kind of blew it here
but let me ask you
here what would be a good idea for white
i missed it during the game though so
let's say you get the perfect attack
you're attacking
what is what do you think you should do
so
well that's what i did i took it and the
game was fine and it ended in a draw i
couldn't really make
make it work
it's still comfortable but i can't do
much opponents can't do much i oh
thank you i'm seeing somebody in the
chat
all right what is the one move that
could give white
like plus six almost
your queen is in a good spot your h2
rook is fine your bishop is as good as
it can get right now
your knight or your other rook are the
ones that could be improved
any final thoughts
how about knight to f4
the idea is simple if you take me well
wonderful
this should be fun
you can't really stop this what's
happening
if you don't take it
you can't you just can't stop this let's
say you take rook takes g4
i can even just go to rook g1
i mean i feel like rook g3 is a little
bit more effective
but that's kind of the idea you need to
be able to come
come up with a
ways to attack more because you only
have two super active pieces on this
king whereas you can easily bring this
knife as well
all right i'm going to do a big jump
back
and
the final thing i wanted to talk about
is yeah just you can castle and you can
just go for this ideas
you don't have to if you don't want to
but you do have the option of long
castle
i've also had a few games in which my
click on my opponent takes take take
take
and then they try to exchange everything
which we also saw a little bit about for
example you can just go like knight b5
and if they take you take you want this
knight to stay in front of this pawn you
want to do upon c3 sometime soon
still a little undecided about this
bishop i could just leave it on d3 i'm
not that excited into exchanging it so
we'll kind of see how things go
but that would be a nice way
um let's see if for example here
opponent goes like pawn a6
i had a long castle game like here i
could start pushing the h pawn too
and you can simply just kind of wait to
see what happens i kind of missed the
knight e4 idea to be completely honest
because i was just not looking for it
and
my opponents i mean you can't really
take because well thanks
you can't take here because well thanks
check
and it was just such a cool but weird
move
and i didn't see it in time during the
game and i went back 92 i ended up
winning the game anyways
but still this would have been much more
pleasant because now i have bishop
the other bishop can get here
so this would be too good to be true
so
i hope you are kind of more comfortable
with some of the potential centers pawn
structures middle games that you would
get
in this specific
uh line of french
and oh my god i'm a little afraid to say
but i think we're done with french oh
does it feel real i don't believe it
fully
but for now we'll say we're done and if
i come up with something else we can
revisit the topic
so we still have a little bit of more
karaoke to cover from next week on but
we'll see we'll see how things are
turning out
uh oh actually i don't think i'm seeing
you on youtube until my
until next week because i believe
tomorrow the streams are not
happening because of gct and
the the tournament and life and i'm glad
i have my graduations this weekend so
keep
keep up with my instagram
and uh i got my mizumet celebration at
some point
keep up with that as well
and uh finally
oh yes please don't forget to be here
six a.m
watch the gct commentary with
um alejandra ramirez yasser sirvan
my potential future coach chirila
and all those fun stuff
6 50 a.m central time
good luck everybody i'll be sound sleep
i will see you later
[Music]
you